I'm one load up SCP but I've also got
pretzels so I'm kind of eating pretzels
seven one four crunch crunch
good okay right you ready all right you
ready you ready bottles so goddamn good
pretzels man they're good huh nice good
pretzel that's good notice mom with
smaller happens a plus yeah forget the
game hang on go back - oh yeah that's a
slice of something pretzel yeah yeah one
more yeah just you ever eat a pretzel
one more one more I can't just oh I
gotta wash it down get too much pretzel
in the gob
[Music]
you feel like you're forgetting
something
yeah one more now stuck all on my teeth
now it's gonna take a bit it's really
stuck in there there we go one more I'll
do to it once I still drive all right
don't drive guys ever have a parental
right to really dry
it's like they made these pretzels
without water maybe it's like every odd
number of pretzels is more moist and the
even numbers are more dry let me try
three [ __ ] desert look just like a
good beat a clip is just sins inside
them I still dry dry gnarled it for I
don't think four would be any any any
wetter I think four would be worse huh I
think for my you think are you a
scientist try five oh god this many left
that's probably I don't think that's
five I mean I'll do four but I just want
to say for the record I don't think you
guys are telling me to do four I don't
think that I I don't think there's gonna
help the situation at all I think this
is only gonna exacerbate it which means
to make it worse trust me he took me
I've been had a fright for is like the
driest of all the combinations I've have
twos dr3 was really dry before takes the
cake go really dry not moist cake those
borderline unpleasant now are all over
the place in my mouth
[Music]
Trillian there hang on guys ever watched
Great British Bake Off now I know why
they don't make pretzels on that show
another sip ah ah I'm gonna go back to
one just to see like if it's Denny
different new
that's fine that's fine
one two fine ones good I like one one
one do I have one more